Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, since Arrow
is on break this week I wanted to do a new
bonus Flash video.
So this is going to be my Top 5 Flash Villains.
We also got a good look at Grant Gustin in
the full costume.
So we should probably talk about that first.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Arrow and Flash videos every week along
with bonus Q&A videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
There’s still several episodes left in season
2 of Arrow and they’ll be filming the Flash
pilot for a couple more weeks.
So first let’s talk about Grant Gustin’s
Flash costume.
As expected it looks more like a tech suit
than straight up fabric like Stephen Amell’s
Arrow suit.
The same person made both of them.
The pictures we’ve seen from the set don’t
include any special effects.
But I think once they edit the footage they’ll
tweak the colors and highlights a little bit.
If you remember when they debuted Stephen
Amell’s costume, it was a much more muted
green color than the bright version in the
comic books.
They turned the color way down mostly for
practical reasons.
One, it’s supposed to help hide his identity.
Two, it can’t be too distracting on camera.
And three, bright colors look a little silly
in real life.
They even muted the blue and red of Superman’s
costume in Man of Steel.
So that’s why the red we’re seeing is
so dark compared to the comic book version.
I think it looks pretty cool, I’m glad they
didn’t go crazy with the yellow lightning
bolt hilights.
It would have been way too distracting.
Their goal is to draw as much attention to
Grant Gustin’s face for viewers like you
and me, while at the same hiding his identity
from the other characters.
Just like you’re always looking at Stephen
Amell’s face on screen, but Detective Lance
never questions his identity.
Here’s a quick history of the different
comic book versions of the Flash Suit starting
with Jay Garrick who may or may not be John
Wesley Shipp in the pilot.
Jay Garrick’s costume has largely remained
unchanged over the years.
When DC Rebooted everything with New 52 they
rebooted Jay Garrick in the Earth 2 series
with this alternate costume.
So currently, this is what he looks like.
But if he does appear in the pilot it’s
possible that they’ll stick with the golden
age version of his costume.
Barry Allen’s costume has also largely stayed
the same since the debut of the character.
During New 52 they did add some more texture
to the flash symbol on his chest though.
As you can see, Grant Gustin’s version is
much less spandexy looking.
Which is a good thing.
We don’t know where he’ll get the costume
yet.
Either from the ring or if it will be like
Stephen Amell’s costume and he’ll physically
have to climb into it like a regular pair
of pants.
This is the Wally West costume, it like the
others has pretty much been the same forever.
The big difference from the Barry Allen costume
is that the nose is covered.
The New 52 version of Wally West, the current
version is actually debuting finally in Flash
Annual #3 April 30th.
So he’ll finally be reintroduced to the
DC Universe just like all the other characters
after Flashpoint.
This is what the brand new version of the
costume will look like.
Imagine it in red though.
This is just a variant.
Be sure to let me know what you think of Grant
Gustin’s costume in the comments and how
you think he’s going to get it.
And now let’s talk some villains.
They’ve already announced the antagonists
of the pilot The Reverse Flash Edward Thawne
and Killer Frost played by Danielle Panabaker.
But if everything goes according to plan there’s
going to be 23 episodes in season 1 just like
Arrow.
So they’re going to need to pull in some
more villains from the comics.
Remember Barry Allen and enemy Edward Thawne
work at a Police Station, so it’s entirely
likely that they’ll be hunting down and
arresting villains every week.
Here are my top 5 that we need to see in season
1.
Remember this is just season 1, so nothing
too crazy like Gorilla Grodd.
Here we go, Number 5 - Heat Wave.
Like some of my other picks he’s one of
the core Rogue’s.
The most frequent recurring group of villains
the Flash runs into.
Heat Wave as a child became obsessed with
fire and is essentially a pyromaniac, the
other Rogues like Captain Cold inspired him
to channel his obsession into a new identity,
which is when he took on the Heat Wave persona.
Post-New 52 he was disfigured when he and
all the other Rogue’s gained their superpowers.
Now he can generate fire naturally from his
body.
It’s likely that on the show if they use
the character, that they’ll use the particle
accelerator explosion to give all the Rogues,
including Heat Wave, their metahuman abilities.
But it’s also possible that they could do
it old school and have him use heat guns like
during Flash Rebirth.
They did imply that we would be seeing more
super powered people on the Flash, but they
didn’t say how many or if everyone would
just have powers at the beginning of the show
or if people would develop them over time.
Number 4 - The Axel Walker Trixter.
He’s the current version of the character
in the comics.
He was a normal person that took the name
from the original Trixter after he died.
Right now in the comics he’s already had
his arm torn off by Gorilla Grodd and is kind
of exiled from the Rogues.
He doesn’t have any superpowers, and is
really more of a nuisance to The Flash.
Think exploding yo-yo’s, he does have a
pair of shoes that allow him to fly for periods
of time.
I can only imagine how the tv show would deal
with that.
Number 3 - Weather Wizard like the other Rogues
also gained superpowers during the New 52
Reboot.
The name explains everything, but because
of the way his powers work, the more he uses
them to control weather, the more depressed
he gets.
Which is kind of funny.
As part of the comics reboot, he goes after
Dr Elias, who the Rogues blame for the accident
that gave them superpowers.
The tv show is substituting the character
Tom Cavanagh is playing Harrison Wells for
the Dr Elias character in the comics.
Harrison Wells is the person who is blamed
for the particle accelerator explosion.
So the rogues on the show will probably try
to get revenge on him at some point and Grant
Gustin will have to stop them.
Number 2 - Captain Cold.
One of the interesting things about the character
is that even though he is a supervillain,
he still has a moral code.
He’s the one usually quoting the phrase,
“Rule Number 1 of the Rogues.
You Never Kill A Flash.”
He does have a sister that he cares about
so of all the second tier Flash villains,
he’s the most complex.
There can be no Flash show without Captain
Cold, so of all the people on my list, he’s
the most likely we’ll see during season
1.
But he’s a pretty big deal, so I don’t
expect him to appear until later in season
1.
During the new 52 comics he ended up working
with and double crossing the Flash.
So on the show he could team up with Grant
Gustin the same way Oliver and Diggle are
teaming up with the Suicide Squad.
and my number 1 villain I want to see in season
1.
The Black Flash.
He’s the physical embodiment of death, so
even though he’s a character.
He’s really more of an abstract idea.
In the comics, the most recent version of
the character is just a negative aspect of
the speed force.
During rebirth Barry Allen was possessed by
the Black Flash and started killing other
people connected to the speed force.
So essentially it’s like balancing the scales
on a physics level.
There’s a positive aspect of the speed force
that Barry Allen and all the other Flashes
get their power from, including Professor
Zoom.
And then there’s the negative aspect of
the Speed Force, which the Black Flash draws
power from.
As you saw earlier in the video, they’re
bringing Wally West back in the comics next
month and he looks like a version of the Black
Flash.
So I’m sure the story will have something
to do with that.
So now it’s your turn, let me know which
of the Rogues or other Flash villains do you
want to see on the show in season 1.
Remember, the crazier villains like Gorilla
Grodd probably won’t come first.
Just like on Arrow, they’ll probably use
the lesser villains first.
Which means the Rogues.
Next week Arrow is back and it’s the Suicide
Squad episode, be sure to subscribe to get
my video.
We’re going to see Harley Quinn for the
first time.
She’s being played by Caitlin Alexa.
You can learn all about that in my last Arrow
video by clicking here and you can click here
to learn more about season 1 of The Flash.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!